فتح تحقيق حول تسريب وثائق امنيه امريكيه
سريه عبر وسائل التواصل تتعلق بالصين
والشرق الاوسط واوكرانيا
نتنياهو يصدر تعليمات بتعبئه جميع وحدات
الاحتياط في القوات الاسرائيليه بعد هجوم
تل ابيب
انتهاءه الاجتماع الامني الليبي في بنغازي
وتاجيل اعلان البيان الختامي الى وقت لاحق
اليوم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى نشره لاهم الانباء
من العربيه يقدمها لكم ابراهيم بدر اعلنت
وزاره العدل الامريكيه عن فتره تحقيق حول
تسريب وثائق امنيه امريكيه سريه عبر وسائل
التواصل وكانت صحيفه
ان مجموعه جديده من الوثائق السريه التي
يبدو انها تتناول بالتفصيل اسرار الامن
القومي للولايات المتحده من اوكرانيا الى
الشرق الاوسط والصين ظهرت على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي يوم امس الجمعه ونقلت
نيويورك تايمز عن محللين قولهم ان التسريب
الذي طال اكثر من 100 وثيقه سريه يضر
كثيرا بوشنطن وانه يشكل خرقا امنيا كبيرا
واضافت الصحيفه ان التسريب يثير قلق
البنتاغون ويبدو انه فاجا اداره بايدن
وكانت تسريب سابق لوثائق عسكريه امريكيه
سريه على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي اعطى
صوره جزئيه للحرب في اوكرانيا واتهم
مسؤولون امريكيون روسيا
بالمسؤوليه عن هذا التسريب فيما لم يصدر
بعد اي تعليق من موسكو
ما قيمه خطط الحرب ان فقدت سريتها فالسريه
قد تكون اهم من الخطه نفسها وتسريبها يعني
هزيمه مسبقه في المعركه قنبله مدويه
فجرتها صحيفه نيويورك تايمز تشير لان اهم
مؤسسه عسكريه في العالم وهي وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه لم تنجح في الحفاظ على سريه
وثائق متعلقه بالحرب الاوكرانيه الاكثر من
ذلك هو ان هذه الوثائق باتت بين يدي الطرف
الاخر في الحرب
روسيا فالوثائق انتشرت على نطاق واسع على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في روسيا ما يشكل
ضربه موجعه للخطط الاوكرانيه في الحرب
فعلى ماذا تحتوي هذه الوثائق تحديدا
الوثائق تقدم لمحه سريعه لما قد تحتاجه
القوات الاوكرانيه في المعركه المرتقبه ضد
روسيا والتي يتم تداولها تحت مسمى حرب
الربيع وتكشف الوثائق عن توجه اوكرانيا
نحو مواصله الاعتماد على منظومه مارس
لصواريخ المدفعيه التي اثبتت فعاليتها في
المعارك ومن بين الاسرار التي كشفت عنها
الوثائق ايضا تشكيل اثني عشره وحده قتاليه
اوكرانيه يتم تدريبها من قبل الولايات
المتحده وحلفاء اخرين في الناتو وتتحدث
الوثائق ايضا عن الجدول الزمني لتسليم
المعدات العسكريه لجيش الاوكراني فضلا عن
معلومات عسكريه اخرى
عمليه تسريب الوثائق هذه قد تدخل ضمن
دائره الحرب النفسيه والاستراتيجيه بين
الطرفين فنقلا عن الصحيفه دائما فان موسكو
قد تكونوا تعمدت نشر الوثائق وتلاعبت في
بعض جزئياتها من اجل تمويه الجيش
الاوكراني وبعثره اوراقها وبعيدا عن مدى
تاثير هذه الوثائق المسربه على اطوار
المعارك فالاكيد ان الحرب النفسيه
والاستراتيجيه باتت تاخذ حيزا اكبر في هذا
الصراع المتواصل وسام الذهبي العربيه
ذكرت وكاله الانباء الروسيه انا المحققين
في جهاز الامن الفيدرالي وجهه تهمه التجسس
الى مراسل صحيفه تورس 3 جورنال ايفان
كريشكوفيتش من جهته نفى مراسل الصحيفه
الامريكيه تهمل الموجهه اليه بشكل قاطع
مؤكدا ان مهمته لا تتعدى كونه صحفيا في
روسيا
اعلن رئيس مجموعه فاجنر شبه العسكريه
الروسيه
عبر قناته على تيليجرام ان قتالا شرسا مع
القوات الاوكرانيه يدور بالقرب من محطه
السكك الحديديه في باخما وكانت القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه قالت في وقت سابق انها
تسيطر على الاوضاع في المدينه رغم صعوبه
الوضع العسكري في المنطقه التي تشهد اعنف
المعارك منذ اندلاع الحرب
التواصل في الخارجيه الفرنسيه في مقابله
مع العربيه انا بلاده ستواصل دعم اوكرانيا
على جميع الاصعده بما في ذلك عسكريه مضيفا
ان الدعم مستمر الى ان تستعيد اوكرانيا
اراضيها من روسيا
سنستمر في دعمنا الكامل لاوكرانيا على كل
الاساتذه السياسيه سعد العسكريه سعد
الاقتصادي والانسان الى اخره سنقوم الى
جانب اوكرانيا حتى النصر كما قال الرئيس
ايمن
وهذا استرجاع اوكرانيا المحتله من روسيا
امر رئيس وزراء الاسرائيلي بنمينه ياهو
بتعبئه جميع وحدات الاحتياط في الشرطه
العسكريه وقوات الجيش بعد هجوم تل ابيب
وقال بيانو صابرون عن مكتب نتنياهو ان
رئيس الوزراء حتى ايضا المواطنين على
اتباع تعليمات الاجهزه الامنيه وجاء قرار
نتنياهو بعد مقتل شخص واصابه سته اخرين
بينهم اصابتان حرجتان جراء عمليه دهس
واطلاقنا في تل ابيب الى جانب مقتلي منفذ
العمليه
وكانت ثلاث مستوطنات اسرائيليات لقيت او
لقيو مسرعهم في عمليه في منطقه الاغوار
قرب الحدود الاردنيه في هجوم هو الرابع من
نوعه خلال الاشهر ثلاثه الماضيه جاء ذلك
بعد ليله من التصعيد على الحدود الشماليه
والغربيه
تصعيد شمالا وغربا تستيقظ اسرائيل على
تصعيد من الشرق في عمليه اسفرت عن مقتل
مستوطنتي في منطقه الاغوار قرب الحدود
الاردنيه تقول المعلومات ان العمليات هي
الرابعه من نوعها في المنطقه خلال الاشهر
الثلاثه الماضيه يشتبه بان شخصين نفذها
بعشرين رصاصه وفي منطقه شبه معزوله سجل
فيها تاخر وصول طواقم الاسعاف والشرطه ظنا
منها انه حادث سير عقب العمليه نشرت
الشرطه الاسرائيليه حواجز متنقله واغلقت
كل المنافذ الى مدينتي اريحا ونابلس
لمحاصره المنفذين من جهته الجيش
الاسرائيلي استدعى جنوده الاحتياط لاسيما
اولئك في الدفاع الجوي وسلاح الجو عدا عن
استدعاء العشرات من ضباط الاحتياط من
القوات الخاصه امر يشي بنيه لتصعيد جديد
ليس على الارض فقط بل ومن الجو ايضا
رائد المصطفى العربيه
في الاثناء وجهها وزير الدفاع الاسرائيليه
بزياده تامين المستوطنات ومحاور تنقل
المستوطنين وذلك بعد اجتماع مع كبار
المسؤولين الامنيين واكد وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي انا مؤسسه الامنيه مستعده للرد
على اي تهديد يواجهوها كما شدد على ان اي
شخص يسعى لايذاء الاسرائيليين سيجد نفسه
في السجن او المقبره حسب تعبيره من جهته
اكد المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي ان تل
ابيب لا تريد التصعيد لكنها مستعده له في
حال فرض عليها
من جهته اتهمه وزير الامن القوميه
الاسرائيلي اتمار المعارضه بالمسؤوله عن
التصعيد بالمسؤوليه عن التصعيد الداخليه
الحالي وقال ابن كثير انها معارضه واصلت
الحاق الاذى باسرائيل ووصفهم بغير
المسؤولين مضيفا انهم مشجعوا من اسماهم
بالاعداء ببدء هجوم عسكري
قالت مصادر العربيه ان مصر اجرت اتصالات
مكثفه مع الجانب الامريكي للوصول الى صيغه
لوقف التصعيد في كافه المدن الفلسطينيه
وافادت مصادر انه افضل مصريه سيسافر الى
تل ابيب لعقد مناقشات موسعه والعمل على
صياغه اتفاق النهائي تلتزم به كل الاطراف
كما ابلغت الفصائل الفلسطينيه القاهره
بمطالبها والتي تمثلت بوقف اسرائيل
للتصعيد في المسجد الاقصى ووقفي عملياتها
العسكريه على قطاع غزه بحسب المصادر اما
اسرائيل فقد ابلغت القاهره عودتها الى
الهدنه انه مرتبط بعدم اطلاق الصواريخ
ومنع العمليات المنفرده التي تستهدف
المستوطنين وفقا لمصادر العربيه
بينما يغامر حزب الله بامن لبنان عبر دعم
الفصائل الفلسطينيه المحسوبه على حماس
يختلف موقف حركه فتح بشان اطلاق الصواريخ
من داخل الاراضي اللبنانيه اما اللاجئون
في المخيمات فيشككوا بعضهم بقدره هذه
الصواريخ فعليا على احداث اي تغيير
الى داخل مخيمات اللجوء يحمل الفلسطينيون
قضيتهم
كل شيء هنا يذكر بوطن غادروه الاعلام
واللافتات وصور من قتل في الداخل دفاعا عن
القضيه
لكن على خريطه لبنان ينقسم الفلسطينيون
فبينما يرى البعض ان الصواريخ التي اطلقت
من جنوبه تخفف الضغط عن فلسطينيين داخل
يؤكد اخرون ان ما يحدث لعبه سياسيه اقحمت
فيها القضيه اللي صار مسرحيه
مسرحيه واضحه ما بعرف كيف احكيها السياسي
بس واضحه انه جنوب مين بيفوت له غير اللي
حاكمينه
واذا حدا يضرب من الفلسطينيه يعني هاي
صارت شماعه لفلسطينيه اذا بدهم من مين
ماشي فهي هاي صارت مسرحيه وواضحه لكل
الشعب العربي اللي موجود بلبنان ان كانوا
فلسطيني ولا مصري ولا لبناني التصعيد
الجنوبيه لبنان تزامن مع زياره اسماعيل
هنيه الى بيروت هي المره الاولى التي يطلق
فيها هذا الكم من القذائف على دفعتين في
اليوم ذاته لتسقط في اماكن ماهوله ضربه لم
تغب عن اجتماع بين امين عام حزب الله
ورئيس المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس الذين
تربطهما اكثر من ساحه بعيدا عن الاقصى كان
في عده غرض مستمره متصاعد وبهداف ايرانيه
بسوريا والحرس الثوري سارع واعلن عن مقتل
مستشارين عسكريا هذا باشر الحرس الثوري
اخذ قرار الرد وبدنا نشير لموضوع الكلام
الاخير لامين العام لحزب الله لما طلع قال
انه اي استهدف اسرائيلي لاي مقيم على
الاراضي اللبنانيه حيحتم رد من لبنان اي
من الحزب فهون كان بيعطي الغطاء العسكري
والامني والسياسي لهيدي العمليه زائد انه
كان في اجتماع مع رئيس مكتب السياسي لحركه
حماس اسماعيل الهنيه مع قائد فيلا القدس
اسماعيل قهمي بالسفاره الايرانيه على
مائده الافطار قبل عشيه انطلاقه او اطلاق
الصواريخ
وفيما تسعى فصائل فلسطينيه لعلاقات بعيده
عن كنف الدوله تؤكد مصادر فتح انها ضد
تحويل فلسطين الى شماعه تعلق عليها سياسات
دول يعيش الفلسطينيون على امل العوده الى
وطن هجروا منه اما اللبنانيون فياملون
باستعاده سياده وطن تحول الى صندوق بريد
لرسائل اقليميه محفوفه بالمخاطر من مخيم
شاتيلا غنوه يتيم العربيه
قالت مديريه امن السليمانيه في كردستان
العراق انفجار وقع قربه سوري البطار ولم
ينتج عنه اصابه وحسب مراسل العربيه فان
قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي
كان موجودا اثناء الانفجار في الاثناء صرح
مصدر امني لقناه العربيه ان الانفجار في
محيط مطار السليمانيه ناجم عن هجوم
بمسيرات تركيه وقالت مصادر العربيه ان
تركيا لم تقصف طائره قائد قصد في
السليمانيه لوجود اجانب على متنها حيث
استخدمت تركيا القصف للتحذير وقالت مديريه
امن السليمانيه ان الرحلات الجويه تستمر
كالمعتاد رغم الانفجار
في اول ردود الفعل التي عقبت الانفجار
اعربت
رئيسه برلمان اقليم كردستان عن رفضها لاي
اعذار لهذا الهجوم الذي وصفته بالجائر كما
شددت على ان كل الهجمات السابقه على
الاقليم غير عادله مطالبه الحكومه بمعامله
جميع مدن اقليم كردستان بنفس المعايير
وبدون اي تمييز
من جهته اذان بافل جلال طالباني الرئيس
الاتحاد الوطني الكردس الثاني هذا الهجوم
الذي اعتبره محاوله عقيمه لزعزعه امن
منطقه السليمانيه واتهم طالباني بعض
الاجهزه الاستخباراتيه الداخليه بالتواطؤ
مع جهات خارجيه لتنفيذ هذه العمليه كما
شدد رئيس الاتحاد الوطني الكردساني على ان
اقليم كردستان ومدينه السليمانيه خط احمر
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه اشار وزير
الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين الى ان التفرد
بالسلطه هو اكثر ما يهدد النظام السياسي
بالانهيار بعد عام 2003 مشددا على ضروره
حصر السلاح بيد الدوله
التفرد في السلطه اذا كان هو
لان القضايا الاخرى ممكن معالجتها تفرط من
الشرطه يعني ديكتاتوريه ولقد راينا في
التاريخ الحديث للعراق انه دوما
الديكتاتوريه كانت الاساس في تدمير البلد
في تدمير المجتمع لا تؤدي لكن
السلاح خارج اطار الدوله ما مقبول هذا
صحيح يجب تنظيمه هذا هذا ايضا صحيح لان
خطر لان الدوله الدوله بالنتيجه تعبر عن
عن كل المجتمع صحيح نتحدث عن الدوله
المكونات هي لكن بالنتيجه تعبر عن كل
المجتمع والدوله لازم تحمل المجتمع كله
وسلاح خارجي اطار الدوله لو كان موجودا
خطر
20 عاما على تشكيل نظام سياسيا جديدا في
العراق البلاد قبل التاسع من ابريل من عام
2003 ليست كما هي بعدها
يوم ليس كباقي الايام على العراق التاسع
من نيسان قبل 20 عام هناك لطلائع الدبابات
الامريكيه في قلب بغداد تعبر على جسر
الجمهوريه في لقطه رسمت مشهدا ضبابيا على
مختلف الصعد
لتصل بعدها فرقه من مشاه البحريه
الاميركيه الى ساحه الفردوس وتسقط تمثال
الرئيس الاسبق صدام حسين معلنه اسقاط نظام
وبدء عهد جديد
قائم على اسس الديمقراطيه كما تزعم
الولايات المتحده
اذا سقط نظام صدام حسين
لتبدا اعمال السلب والنهب وسرقه المؤسسات
الحكوميه بشكل شبه منظم من اقصى جنوب
العراق وصولا الى شماله
حلم اسقاط النظام تحول بنظر كثيرين الى
كابوس بات يؤرق العراقيين في صحوهم
ومنامهم اكثر المتفائلين واشد المتشائمين
لم يرسموا في مخيلتهم مشهدا كالذي عاشه
العراق طيله العشرين سنه الماضيه الان
سيبدا او بدات بوادر النضوج الفكري
والسياسي حول المشاريع الوطنيه رغم انها
متجذره كواقع حقيقه الامر ولكن كمشروع
امثل هو المنقذ العراق هو المشروع الواقعي
والمشروع الوطني لينقذ العراق من شمال
العراق الاجنوب العراق كان مسؤول على ثلاث
قضايا مهمه اللي هي اسلحه الدمار الشامل
وعلاقته بسبتمبر ويؤدد الامن والسلم
الدوليه وثبت انه هذه الثلاثه هي حقيقه ما
موجوده حقيقه الامر
حجه التدخل العسكري كانت اسلحه الدمار
الشامل والتي لم يجد لها الاميركان ومن
معهم اثرا حتى بعد عشرين عاما من الخراب
والدمار في بلاد ما بين النهرين
لتخلف من بعدها نظاما لا يزال ابائه
المؤسسون يقولون انه في بداياته ولم يمضج
بعد بينما يراه اخرون اسما
مجردا من محتواه سامر الكبيسي العربيه
بغداد
نشرتنا مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعض الفاصل
الصين تجري مناورات عسكريه ودوريات
للاستعداد القتالي حول تايوان
اهلا بكم من جديد اعرب رئيس مجلس السياده
في السودان عبد الفتاح البرهان عن رغبته
في الوصول الى اتفاق نهائي باكبر كتله
تقود الفتره الانتقاليه البرهان قال اذا
لم يتم جمع اكبر كتله من التوافق في الحل
هو افساح المجال للاخرين
انتهى الاجتماع الامنية بين القيادات
الامنيه والعسكريه في شرق وغرب ليبيا
وينتظر اعلان بيان الختام اليوم وافاد
مراسل العربيه بان القيادات الامنيه
والعسكريه في طرابلس وبرغازي اتفقت على
توحيد الجهود للوصول الى اجراء الانتخابات
وان الاجتماع الامني تم بحضور المبعوث
الاممي وتجاوز الطرفان عقبات عديده ونقاطا
خلافيه من ابرزها تنسيق العمل الامني على
مستوى وزارتي الداخليه والدفاع
وقد اشاد رئيس الحكومه الليبيه المكلفه من
البرلمان فتحي بشاغه باجتماعات اللجان
العسكريه الليبيه واعتبرها خطوه على طريق
توحيد المؤسسات العسكريه والامنيه بشر قال
على فيسبوك انه لن تكون هناك حكومه قادره
على اجراء الانتخابات دون توحيد المؤسسات
العسكريه والامنيه ورفض بشغات تلميحات
اشارت الى ان الغرض من المساعي التي تقوم
بها لجنه 5 + 5 هو زج الليبيين في اتون
حرب ضد قوات فاغنر الروسيه
نقله رويترز عن مصادر قولها ان وفدا
سعوديا عمانيا يعتزم التوجه الى صنعاء
الاسبوع المقبل لبحث هده دائمه بين
اليمنيين واوضحت المصادر ان الاطراف
اليمنيه قد تعلن عن اتفاق هدنه قبل عيد
الفطر في العشرين من ابريل اذا نجحت
المحادثه
وكانت صحيفه الشرق الاوسط نقلت عن مصادر
يمنيه ان مسوده خطه السلام الشامله للازمه
في اليمن باتت في اخر مراحل اعدادها
برعايه امميه حيث تتضمن اربع مراحل اولها
وقف شامل لاطلاق النار في البلاد وفتحوا
جميع المنافذ البريه والجويه والبحريه ثم
تشكيل لجان لدمج البنك المركزي وتبادل
الاسرى والمعتقلين تليها مرحله التفاوض
المباشر لتاسيس شكل الدوله واخيرا المرحله
الانتقاليه
ارسل تاجر الاسلحه الروسي السابق فيكتور
بوت برقيه الى الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب عبر تطبيق تيليجرام اعرب
فيها عم خوفه بشان سلامه الرئيس الامريكي
السابق وقدم له ملاذا امنا في روسيا
اعتقد انه من مصلحه البشريه جمعاء وقبل كل
شيء الى الشعب الامريكي دعوه هنا الى
روسيا لتزويده اولا بالامن والحمايه حتى
يقود هذه الانتفاضه ضد دعاه العولمه
والاهم من ذلك انه لم يسمح بتدمير شعبه
الامريكي ربما يكون هذا باختصار ما اريد
ان انقله الى دونالد ترامب في برطيه
اول مرشح ديمقراطيه حدى السيد البيت
الابيض الحالي حيث اعلن روبرت كندي جونيور
ترشحه لمنصب الرئيس رغم ان فرص وفوزه
ضئيله في انتخابات الحزب لكنها ترشحه قد
يفتح الباب حين اخرين نادي البلبيسي معها
التفاصيل
[تصفيق]
روبوت كندي جونير ابن المدعي العام الذي
اغتيل في الستينات الروبرت كندي وابنه اخي
الرئيس جون كندي وعمه كان السنه
ينحدر من اشهر العائلات الامريكيه عرقه
وهي عائلتك كندي يريد اعاده دور الاسره
التي لعبت دورا مهما في الحياه السياسيه
الامريكيه من اوسع الابواب ويطمح للوصول
الى هنا الى البيت الابيض في هذا المكان
حكم الشاب الوسيم جون اف كندي الولايات
المتحده لكن حكمه لم يدم طويلا فقد اغتيل
عام
1963 وبعده اغتيل اخوه روبرت وهو روبرت
جونيور يعود مره اخرى يعلن الترشح ويريد
ان يعود بنا بالذاكره الى عهد تو يا سابقا
روبرت كندي يتحدى الرئيس الديمقراطي جو
بايدن الذي لم يعلن بعد ترشحها الرسمي
لولايه ثانيه كاندي هو محامي شرس يدافع عن
البيئه وهو معروف بمعارضته الشديده
لاستخدام اللقاحات وهي قضيه سجال عرضته
لانتقادات كثيره من الجناح التقليدي
والمحافظ في الحزب الديمقراطي
لا اعتقد ان روبرت كندي لابن سيقطع شوطا
كبيرا في عمليه الترشيح للانتخابات ليس
عليه فقط مواجهه الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن
بل عليه ايضا مواجهه حقيقه ان الكثير من
الديمقراطيين يتساءلون ان كان ديمقراطيا
بدرجه كافيه الافكار التي تحدث عنها كثيره
في السنوات الماضيه تتضمن رفض اللقاح
فيروس كورونا وهذا ليس موقفا شائعا بين
الديمقراطيين
فرص كندي في الوصول للبيت الابيض ان لم
تكن معدومه لكن التحدي هي للرئيس بايدن قد
يفتح الباب لمرشحين اخرين وخصوصا وان
الكثير من علامات الاستفهام تدور حول
تقدمه في العمر وصحته العقليه واحتفاضه
بنائبه الرئيس كاملا هاريس كمرشحه معه
جميعها امور تقلق الديمقراطيين الذين
يحمسون لكن لم ينتقدوا الرئيس بايدن في
العالم بعد نادي البلبيسي العربيه واشنطن
اعلنت كوريا الشماليه انها اجرت اختبارا
جديدا على غواصه نوويه مسيره قادره علشان
هجوم نووي يمكنه التسبب بما وصفته تسونامي
اشعاعي واسع النطاق عبرا انفجار تحت
المياه وكان معهد ابحاث علوم الدفاع
الوطني في كوريا الشماليه اجرى اختبارا
على نظام سلاح استراتيجي تحت الماء بين
الرابع والسابع من ابريل كما اجرت الغواصه
النوويه مسيره هيلتو محاكاه تحت المياه
قطعت خلالها مسافه الف كيلو متر
بدات الصين مناورات عسكريه حول تايوان من
اليوم السبت لمده ثلاثه ايام وعرضت بكين
تنظيم دوريات استعداد
لدوريات للاستعداد القتالي وتدريبات حول
مضيق تايوان والى الشمال والجنوب والشرق
منها وقال الجيش الصيني ان هذه المناورات
هي بمثابه تحذير صارم ضد من وصفهم
الانفصاليون
بدذه من وصفتهم بالانفصاليين متواطئين
الاستقلال تايوان في مقاله تدريبات
العسكريه الصينيه انها تهدد الاستقرار
والامن في المنطقه
في احدث رساله تعونيه الى الجاره الصينيه
رئيسه تايوان تجدد التاكيد على عدم الرضوخ
وذلك بعد زياره امريكا قال خلالها رئيس
مجلس النواب الامريكي كما كارتي تعلمنا
الدرس من اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اظهرنا للمجتمع الدولي ان تايوان ستكون
اكثر اتحادا في مواجهه الضغوط والتهديدات
ولم ترضخ للقمع ولن تتوقف عن التواصل مع
العالم بسبب المعوقات كانت هذه احدث رساله
توجهها تايوان على لسان الرئيسه
عقب عودتها من الولايات المتحده واجتماعها
بالرئيس مجلس النواب الامريكي كيفن
استبقت اللقاء والرساله بدفع المزيد من
السفن الحربيه الى محيط تايوان عدا عبور
مقاتله ومروحيه مضاده للغواصات منطقه
الدفاع الجوي في الجزيره وتحرك حامله
الطائرات شان دونج الى الجنوب الشرقي من
تايوان الامريكيون اعادوا التاكيد على
تمسكهم بدعم تايبي بالاسلحه كونهم تعلم
الدرس من اوكرانيا هذا درس اساسي
استخلصناه من اوكرانيا بمعنى ان العقوبات
وحدها لن توقف احدا في المستقبل
المستقبل الذي تحدث عنه مكافي تواعدته
بكين برد حازم وقوي للدفاع عن سيادتها
ووحده اراضيها كما تقول رد ما زال ضمن
التهديد والوعيد وقد تترجمه على ارض
الواقع
كشفت صحيفه الامريكيه ان ارتفاع عدد
الرعايه الغربيين لدى حكم الطلبان يحملوا
عده رسائل من بينها الضغط للاعتراف بهم او
فردي سيطرتهم وقوانينهم
20 عاما لم تكفي افغانستان لتتنفس بها
السعداء حتى جثمت عليها حكومه طالبان
مجددا قبل نحو عامين ومع عودتها ارجعت
معها تاريخا في احتجاز الغربيين كرهائن
مقابل مبادلتهم بخدمه سياسيه تقول صحيفه
الامريكيه ان طالبان تلجا الاعتقالات
ممنهجه لرعايه امريكيين من اجل تامين
النفوذ السياسي ضد الولايات المتحده وفي
هذا السياق طرحت الصحيفه اربع نظريات اولا
تهدف طالبان الى تخليص افغانستان من اي
وجود غربي لتستطيع احكام السيطره على
قيمها كمنع الفتيات من التعليم اما ثانيا
رجحت المصادر الامنيه ان تخطط طالبان
لاستخدام الرهائن كورقه سياسيه تضمن بها
مبادله الاسرى
وربما تعتبرها خطوه للضغط على اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن للافراج عن
مليارات الدولارات من الاحتياطيه الاجنبيه
المجمده بسبب العقوبات الماليه الامريكيه
وانتهاء بنظريه الاخيره تسعى طالبان من
خلال السجناء السياسيين الى المحاوله
بالاعتراف بحكومتها في كل المحافل الدوليه
التي ما تزال تعتبر في نظر امريكا والغرب
خريجه عن القانون وغير مرغوب فيها
وقدرت مصادر الصحيفه الامريكيه ان
المعتقلين الغربيين اكثر من عشره وسط
زياده مقلقه في دبلوماسيه الرهائن
يشهد العراق انتشارا جديدا لمرض الحمى
النزفيه ففي الناصريه جنوبا تم تسجيله
اصابات جديده تحاول دوائر الصحه والزراعه
تكثيف الجهود للحد منها
مره اخرى تسجل دوائر الصحه في الناصريه
جنوب العراق حالات اصابه بالحمى النزفيه
الفيروس الذي ينتقل عبر الملامسه من
الحيوان الى الانسان عن طريق الحشرات
والبعوض وكان العام الماضي تسبب في وفاته
اربعين شخصا واصابه
378 سجلت محافظه ذي قار خلال الربع الاول
من عام 2023 خمسه اصابات بمرض الحمى
النزفيه من ضمنها ثلاثه
وفيات
الاصابات في هذا الوقت نوعا ما مبكره جدا
مما ينذر
بموسم قاسي
واحتماليه كبيره لتفشي مرضي مع ارتفاع
درجات الحراره
توضح الدوائر الصحيه في جنوب العراق خطوره
هذه الامراض المعديه وكيفيه التسببها بعلل
شديده تهدد حياه الانسان مثلي تلف جدران
الاوعيه الدمويه الصغيره والحد من قدره
الدم على التخثر وقدرت الدوائر الصحيه
نسبه الوفيات نتيجه الفيروس الى ما يقارب
اربعين بالمئه واقع الصحي يعني ينظر بخطر
وبالتالي يفترض ان تكون هناك مجاميع طبيه
وصحيه تتابع المواطن وبؤر يعني ظهرت فيها
هذه الجرثومه وهذه العشره لمكافحتها وايضا
توعيه الناس توعيه المواطنين ويعني دور
الحكومه المحليه ان يكون لها دور واسع
والدور كبير
محل سوى الوقايه وهو ما تنصح به المنظمات
الطبيه السكان المحليين وضروره التزامهم
بالتعليمات الصحيه للحد من مخاطر الوباء
وانتشاره لقناتي العربيه والحدث شاكر عواد
الناصريه
انخفض عدد السكان في ايطاليا الى مستوى
تاريخ هذا العام حيث زادت اعداد الوفاه
بشكل كبير مقابل تراجع نسب المواليد ما
ادى الى استمرار اعلاني حاله الطوارئ
الوطنيه
تقلص بشري حاله طوارئ في ايطاليا انخفاض
اعداد السكان الى مستوى تاريخي
قله المواليد مقابل اعداد الوفيات يوميا
ايطاليا تعيش بكبار السن
زاد من تفوق اعمارهم مئه عام ثلاث مرات في
20 عاما الماضيه
واحد من كل اربعه اشخاص يزيد عمره عن 65
عاما
توقعات رسميه بان تفقد ايطاليا خمس سكانها
مستقبلا
ليبلغ عددهم 54 مليونا في عام 2050 ثم 47
مليونا في عام 2070
رئيسه وزراء ايطاليا كانت تعهدت باصلاح
ومتابعه الامر في انتخابات العام الماضي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات